dudes we got to talk about the Silver
Gate thing because I know that uh I'm
sure dragos and uh big will have some
feedback on it too but you guys know
what's going on hopefully in the chat
with silvergate it's it's like the
biggest bank to fail in the U.S since
2008. it's um
silicon Silicon Valley Bank I mean
Silicon Valley Bank apparently rates are
failing Down Sweet yeah well apparently
Harry and Megan had almost all of their
money in silvergate so there's so
there's some shatter right now on
Twitter right now about them losing a
fast fortune and people are hilariously
celebrating and then you got this issue
yeah and then you got this issue with um
here I got to put this up on the screen
too so you guys can see this uh usdt is
now trending so apparently
um you know these like stable coins
which are purportedly supposed to be
stable you know into perpetuity which
you know you know is obviously not true
because they're all Goose by the system
The Matrix
um someone accidentally swapped over two
million dollars of some [__] coin and
receive five cents usdt because they
didn't let this because they didn't set
the slippage right there's all kinds of
[__] falling apart with the crypto
market right now and I think they
swapped they swapped two million dollars
of usdc for five cents of usdt no it's
um what was the [__] coin that they or
is it again let me scroll back yeah and
I'll find it
um oh [__] I lost it did it update the
feed or something
I think I have it on my last uh story
it's uh where is it
no it's not it no I lost it they pulled
it out of my feed for some
no here it is swap two million what's
three CRV that's some kind of [__] coin
right no that's uh um curve
um
uh stable coin I think
I lost 2 million due to a bug on Cyber
swap I want to swap two million
three curve to usdt which is another
stable coin
and I set the slippage to 0.5 however I
received almost Zero's usdt the fact is
your program has a bug causing me huge
losses is there is there any Insurance
Fund available the guy lost two million
dollars and he's trying to claim
so that's his email I guess but where
was that where was the screenshot of The
Ether scan anyway dude dude apparently
screwed up
um
so you get a liquidity token uh when you
deposit and um
curve uh liquidity pool that's what he
sought so it's supposed to be equal to
one dollar yeah so you know you guys
need to figure out what the hell you're
doing when you're using crypto anyway so
usdt or sorry usdc which is the main
stable coin that's tied into silvergate
which should be locked or pegged to the
US dollar is now worth 91 sets and I
think I saw it drop down to 70 cents at
1.2 I saw this coming yesterday and I
and I swapped every usdc token that I
have
[Music]
except for a small amount which was
locked up so I got to wait till later on
this afternoon so maybe I'll get 91
cents on the dollar or whatever but yeah
yeah like I saw this coming yesterday
and I got out of all of my usdc you want
to know something really funny I had
like each time one of these collapses
happened I had massive exposure to it
just a few days before yeah so when
Celsius happened I withdrew maybe 20 30
days I think before
when Luna happened I had just sold when
FDX happened I had just withdrawn to my
bank account when this happened I had
just put my money deposited my money
into a Forex broker
and it's now in dollars not in
stablecoin
yeah stablecoin ain't always as stable
as they purport it to be obviously and
you know there's your proof in the
putting especially when there's [__]
going down and all these financial
institutions are tied into these staples
you guys got to pay attention to stuff
man it's like there's lots of
opportunities in this volatility to make
lots of money too yeah
this is a fight between
the US government basically the
Democrats side
um that are we're backing FTX and circle
and the counterpart is CZ
do you think cz's laughing right now
I think it's payback for them
um
blocking busd through paxos
could be
also these Banks were have failed due to
investments in normal uh financial
instruments so not crypto
I guess
I guess the upside all this is it's it's
going to push a lot of money out of
stables probably into Bitcoin
um which seems to be holding the Bitcoin
price reasonably stable for the time
being but I still think we're going to
see the crypto Market below 16 15 000 in
the next little while
I'm not sure it's going to happen now
though
is going to happen maybe in October
November because
there were some entries of big players
that don't usually make mistakes
those big players would be who
um just some wallets I
um whales you follow yeah
this is like 100 the best way of making
money
Silicon Valley Bank basically did it to
themselves yeah there's just too much
Venture Capital Money chasing around
it's just too much free money that's
pretty much what it was though right and
it's just like just putting money into
just whatever [__] company and then the
value is based on nothing based on hopes
and dreams and wants and wishes but
nothing really how's the cards
if you can get on that side
and nothing like not just that we're not
worth anything like we have a seven
million dollar evaluation it's like we
don't do anything we haven't produced
anything I I love working for companies
like we have users we have users they
have an idea
it's not just that but just the the the
um what's we're looking for like the the
perks in these companies are
astronomical like this just you know
they they pay for all your meals they
pay for all the you know the campus they
have these way over bloated like you
know employee rosters then they're
paying these people crazy amounts it's
Adult Day Care I've worked for those
companies where it's really cool at
first like oh they have this awesome
chef and they do they can do my laundry
on site and there's a gym on site and
they can wash my car and they can clean
my shoes and they wow they do everything
here on campus and then you realize I'm
literally all day here it's like I'm
back in college I'd live at the place
because there's no reason for me to
leave work now so that the other things
just pay me man the other thing is that
like sometimes they're just like I just
want to work I don't want to play video
games yeah I don't want I don't want to
play foosball like I just want to work
you know can I do this
there is an argument for office culture
and I I I got heavily involved in this
um back in late 2000s to up to about
2011-12 so about four or five years like
I've put a lot of money into office
culture and you know we had um we had a
lot of benefits we had like a games room
we had a gym we had a like a car wash
studio with a pressure washer barbecue
and show like we had a lot of cool stuff
in our office
um but we never went to like full like
later yeah like full sort of return yeah
as they said an adult day care like
basically yeah right you know where they
have like these naptime sleep pods you
know sort of thing and people don't
really work and all their meals are paid
for and like stuff like that like on
Fridays I would I would bust out the uh
spadooch tray and you know take out the
lamb and season it and I you know I do
like a lamb spadooch on lunch I sort of
walk around and pass out sticks
everybody because that's my thing like I
like to do that right and people you
know really appreciate it but like the
level of of like adult daycare that they
run in a lot of Silicon Valley companies
like I don't know how the productivity
rates even exist yeah how the profit
rates even exist if they spend all this
time and money just doing this and
people get upset when they get laid off
like oh I have to find a real job now
right
the the thing is rich is that it's all
[__] though right like I don't know
about your company but I know with a lot
of these big Silicon Valley companies
that have like 50 000 employees like
when the rubber hits the road and you
know interest rates go up they lay off
10 000 people so all their talk of like
oh it's a culture you know it's we're
like a fat oh we're a family here we're
family giving you all this free stuff we
care about you no because you know again
when interest rates go up slightly
they're still making money all these
companies right they're just laying off
people because it's a liability on their
balance sheet they just want to improve
their balance sheet do stock BuyBacks
right that's something a lot of guys
learn the hard way in their career and
that it's not a family when they get
laid off like oh my God I can't believe
it Josh fluke does a lot of videos on
his channel you'll see on LinkedIn like
oh I'll miss my family and I'm and I'll
miss the extension of me and my my
everything and it's like okay don't make
your job your entire life I love the
remote first culture because I'm usually
pretty singular focused when it's time
to work it's time to work when I'm done
I'm done I don't want to [__] around
anymore I don't want to sit around and
do do powwows and huros and and sing
lullabies and Merry-Go-Round songs that
a lot I don't like do you can go to just
let me do my work 100 go way too far
I'll even say like where I went I
probably went a little bit too far but
Silicon Valley takes it up to the next
level speaking of Silicon Valley and
Silicon Valley Bank there's that article
I was telling you about earlier about
it's all Elia just tweeted this out he
goes please God please let this be true
and at the in the in the caption is
breaking Harry and Megan stand to lose
millions in the collapse of svb Bank
sources tell Isn a couple set up an
account following the advice of friends
in Silicon Valley this is a major blow
they had all of Harry's money in there
[Music]
wait can you smell that smells like
divorce is coming for him well he has no
he he has no house in London so I don't
know where he's going to live now right
well I'm sure any royal family will take
him back in I mean they're not going to
let him is he going to get paparazzi to
like another prominent member of the
royal family some years ago who knows
didn't go bankrupt before because of VCS
they went bankrupt because they bought
treasuries
right so when you deposit your funds
with a bank they eventually have to do
something with that money they don't
just hold it so they put it into
treasuries and and as the
um money rate went up the value of the
treasuries went down so when they had to
liquidate because people wanted their
money back they did so at a discount and
they couldn't take the loss basically
there was a run on the bank though and
and keep in mind this all just happened
less than 24 hours ago so yeah I'm not
quite caught up to speed on this but um
yeah what I understand you know like
they are they were the bank for a lot of
the Silicon Valley companies like I'm
just reading right now like I know Roku
the the streaming um company in Roku had
25 percent of their cash
in svb and it's it's not insured so like
you know they say there's not going to
be much contagion but I mean when you
have a company like Roku and who knows
what other companies had all their cash
all their cash and
it's bank and then it just goes bust
and what you have to understand is that
most of these Banks cannot put their
money into other assets except bonds
they aren't allowed
so the only place that they can get
exposure
is against the the government and the US
dollar and when they increase the rates
they decrease the value of these bonds
and basically they need to sell them at
a loss
so this was 100
classic Financial system issue
you'll see um you'll see the follow-up
of this next week yeah
because most the markets have been
closed yeah I think they get bailed out
you think so yeah and some weight
Maybe
money printer go Burr
yeah something I don't know what because
they probably need to hide it in some
way right because they don't want it to
be like hey we're bailing out a bank
but but even then the shock to the
confidence of the system is the damage
has been done already right you know
even if they are bailed out that's right
there's just like
accept the
the the classical dollar
one place where you can put your money
and not be scared that you might lose it
is Bitcoin maybe ethereum in these
volatile moments yeah I really hope you
guys enjoyed that clip if you want to
watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out